Democrats fight over impeachment the
squad takes the lead again and Joe Biden
vows to reorient before next week's big
debates i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show all right we have a lot to
get to today so let's just jump right in
the fact is that the democrats are
divided over what to do about
impeachment and this divide is mirroring
the divide between AOC and Nancy Pelosi
this of course is going to be the
running gun battle that goes all the way
through the 2020 election it's certainly
going to take place in the primaries as
we'll see it's reflected in Joe Biden
versus kamo Harris and Elizabeth Warren
but it's not coming together anytime
soon now a couple of weeks ago this was
breaking right out in the open
AOC was saying that Nancy Pelosi was a
vicious brutal racist and Pelosi
for her part was saying that AOC was a
neophyte who really didn't know what she
was doing and they've been saying this
about each other kind of in softer ways
for months AOC had been saying for
months that Nancy Pelosi was freezing
her out she was the teenage girl whose
mom wouldn't let her use the car and she
was really mad about it after all mom I
know how to use the car Pelosi was like
well last time I drove with you you ran
into a tree so we're not doing that
again that was the argument and then it
was papered over by the fact that
President Trump couldn't keep his tweet
shut and so he just decided to tweet out
a bunch of stuff about how about how
much he hates the squad and how the
squads really bad and they should go
back to their home countries and all of
this and we all remember that
controversy well it turns out that
controversy is not going to be papered
over by unification against Trump for
very long because in the end Democrats
are going to have to settle this one way
or another being in the opposition
papers over a lot of internal
differences this is something that
Republicans found out when they were in
the opposition when they were in the
opposition to President Obama then it
was unity unity we can't stand Obama's
agenda we're all gonna unify to fight
Obama's agenda in every conceivable way
then they went back to house and it
turns out they can't get anything done
because the freedom caucus is it war
with the more moderate members of the
caucus and it turns out that Paul Ryan
is at war with other members of the
caucus it turns out that some members of
the caucus wants entitlement reform and
other members of the caucus don't want
entitlement reform it turns out their
vast divisions inside each one of the
parties it's an additional check and
balance that the founders never really
thought about and for all the talk about
unification within the parties the truth
is that there is no unification within
the parties now what's interesting is
that unification from the outside
appears to be pretty cohesive simply
because the lack of unity is not around
ideological agenda it's around means
meaning that it used to be that inside
the Republican Party there were a lot of
pro-choice people there are a lot of
pro-life people now it turns out it's
mostly paralyzed people almost entirely
in the Democratic Party there were
pro-life people and pro-choice people
now you can number the pro-life people
in the Democratic Party on one hand so
what exactly are the battles about
they're about means there are the folks
who are pragmatists in the Republican
Party this would be sort of Mitch
McConnell maybe Kevin McCarthy in the
house and then there are the ideologues
the people who are sticking to principle
no matter what and in that category and
the Senate II could probably put Rand
Paul and Mike Lee and then in the house
you could put the members of the freedom
caucus ready that would sort of be the
divide well in the Democratic Party
you're seeing the same thing happened on
the presidential level and you're seeing
that happen in the House Nancy Pelosi is
the pragmatist she's reading the tea
leaves she's figuring out how to get
things done she's trying to work with
the opinion of the American people and
move forward with an agenda on which she
largely agrees with aoc and then he got
a OC and AOC has more as we would say
about any other politician balls than
brains I mean she's running directly
into the line of fire and she is saying
let's just do all of this at once we got
to do it all it doesn't matter what the
polls say doesn't matter what the
American people want it's time it's our
time now it's our time okay so this is
all the prelude to the discussion of
impeachment
so a wing of the Democratic Party wants
to push forward with impeachment despite
the fact that the robert muller hearing
the other day when incredibly poorly for
democrats it was not good for robert
muller it did not bring to light any
additional facts which we did not know
and I think that Democrats were they
they keep operating under the same
assumption they've been operating in in
presidential politics for a really long
time which is that if something they say
is unpopular it's because they didn't
communicate it properly so when Al Gore
was running for president the idea was
he didn't win not because his program
was unpopular but because Al Gore was
just too intellectual for the American
people which is a hell of a thing Al
Gore is not too intellectual for anyone
they do the same thing with John Kerry
in 2004 the reason that John Kerry lost
wasn't because his message was bad it
wasn't because he was a
peacenik in a time of war no it was
really because John Kerry was just too
smart for the average American we've
gotten the same thing with Hillary
Clinton she was just too smart for the
average American
the average American wants the Homer
Simpson light that is Donald Trump right
that was the line from the Democratic
Party and they're doing the same thing
now with regard to impeachment and the
Mobil report so most Americans actually
have a fairly good idea of what was in
the model report a lot of bad behavior
by the president nothing criminal and
that's all they're gonna take away from
it they're not going to take away from
it that he was a Russian stooge because
he wasn't they're not gonna take away
from it that the president is
impeachable because he really is not
what they're gonna take away from it is
that the president is exactly who they
thought he was in the first place namely
a guy who mouths off a lot makes a lot
of empty threats the president is a dude
who's willing to take help from pretty
much anybody no matter where it comes
from and I mean for goodness sake the
president has said all this stuff out
loud it's not like Trump has been shy
about anything right are we supposed to
be shocked by the fact that the Trump
campaign was welcoming of Russian offers
even if no collusion took place why
would we be Donald Trump got up on the
stump in 2016 and called on WikiLeaks to
release Hillary Clinton's emails and
started shouting from the stage I love
WikiLeaks he wasn't exactly hiding the
ball here guys
but Democrats seem to be under the
impression before the Muller hearing
that all they truly had to do was
reexpose Americans to the deep dark
secrets of a Mullen report that had been
in public release for several months at
this point and all 448 pages available
and that Muller would stand there and be
strong and decisive and that this would
privately provide the impetus for
impeachment well that didn't happen but
that's not stopping some members of the
Democratic Party well get some more of
that in just one second first it's time
to be an adult you know you don't think
too often about death because how could
you live your life if you were thinking
about death all the time it's depressing
but there is one situation in which you
really do have to think about death at
least for five minutes and that is when
you're thinking about buying life
insurance you should buy life insurance
it is the adult thing to do but you
don't want to think about death or life
insurance for more than five minutes and
this is where my friends at policy
genius come in policy genius is the easy
way to shop for life insurance online in
just two minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
and find your best price once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape there's
no sales pressure no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of
policy geniuses entrusted life insurance
they do auto insurance they do health
insurance they do disability insurance
anything you're looking for insurance
wise policy genius can probably help you
so if you need a life insurance but you
just don't want to deal with all the
legwork head on over to policy genius
calm think about that for just five
seconds here and make sure that policy
genius gets your life insurance taken
care of don't leave your family bereft
you've been a good adult it's the easy
way to compare all top insurers find the
best value for you policy genius calm
delegate what you hate especially if
what you hate is getting life insurance
okay so how does this play out it plays
out in that Muller
in the Muller hearing doesn't go well
everybody basically acknowledges this
even the New York Times acknowledges
this so there's a piece by Carl hulls in
the New York Times today titled lack of
electricity and Muller testimony short
circuits impeachment says President
Trump was probably never going to be
impeached in the House of
Representatives before the twenty20
elections the testimony by robert muller
the former special counsel makes that in
near certainty the absence of an
electrifying washington moment in
wednesday's two-stage testimony by
Muller not only deprive Democrats of the
crystallizing episode they needed to
drive public opinion on impeachment but
it also meant that Republicans had no
reason to budge from their anti
impeachment stance pressure will
continue to come from the left and could
become so irresistible that Judiciary
Committee begins what it will call an
impeachment inquiry without a formal
house vote but that is very different
from a vote in the full house to
formally declare that an elected
president committed high crimes and
misdemeanors for only the second time in
history Andrew Johnson wasn't selected
so that would be the third Pro
impeachment Democrats have always
labored under the burden of trumps
iron-fisted control over his own party
okay the the sort of language from the
New York Times is always amusing Barak
Obama also had some fairly iron-fisted
control over his own party breaks in the
ranks of the president's party always
drove major congressional White House
investigations in the past including
Watergate iran-contra and the
impeachment of President Bill Clinton 31
Democrats voted with Republicans in
October 1998 to open an impeachment
inquiry into mr. Clinton but the plain
fact is that nothing Muller could have
said would have been sufficient to pry
the vast majority of pro-trump
Republicans from their refusal to even
consider that mr. Trump acted illegally
in trying to thwart a wide-ranging
investigation into his actions okay well
again the Mullah report was supposed to
provide that Evan
if Muller had come forth and said listen
impeachable there's an impeachment ready
the same way that the Starr report said
and the Starr reports a little different
because the scope of his authority under
the Independent Counsel Act was broader
than Muller's was here but if Muller had
come forward and just said I would
recommend prosecution but we can't under
the OLC
impeachment would be moving full full
ahead Republicans probably would have
peeled off you would have had a serious
impeachment effort but that's not what
mama provided right now there are only
91 representatives who support an
impeachment inquiry 106 okay and this
among Democrats 106 do not support so
that is not nearly enough to get this
done well there's still Democrats who
want to charge full speed ahead into the
middle of this thing and that is not
smart but it's understandable after all
they've been told that Donald Trump is
the most evil person who has ever lived
and thus Donald Trump must be impeached
whether or not they have the evidence
now there are still people like Matt
Iglesias who are who are trying to claim
over and over that impeachment would not
be bad for Democrats but that is
obviously false Nate Silver's has way
too many 3d chess theories on how
impeachment would benefit Democrats
politically can't even grapple with the
simple fact that polls show the
impeaching Trump as being deeply
unpopular and no it's not just because
of Pelosi lack of support impeachment is
really unpopular with independence and
then he links to a Washington post/abc
News poll from June 28th to July 1st a
pretty recent poll and it shows that
among among independents fully fifty
nine percent say no impeachment only 37
percent say yes impeachment well there's
still Democrats who say well that's just
because we have to educate the American
public again this is back to the old Al
Gore Hillary Clinton John Kerry line
we've been too sophisticated in our
approach I promise you guys it's not
that he had CNN running interference for
your impeachment nonsense for literally
two years nonetheless this is breaking
out into the open and it's
representative by the by the women of
the view many of the women of the view
who represent the heart and soul of the
Democratic Party they're demanding that
Adam Schiff impeach President Trump and
that includes of course Anna Navarro the
titular Republican who of course hasn't
really been a Republican for several
years at this point what you said was
you know
the perfect case for collusion so if
we've got those facts that we've got
that information how do you justify to
the American people not following up
with an impeachment inquiry well the
Constitution provides impeachment as a
remedy it doesn't compel Congress to act
and impeach whenever there are grounds
for impeachment and I think we have to
consider what will an impeachment and an
acquittal in the Senate say about
whether this president's conduct is
compatible with office if the president
can later make the claim having been
acquitted that this is not impeachable
conduct so I do think about what message
we are sending today okay weird that
Adam Schiff would suddenly back off
impeachment when he's been saying for
years that he has undercover information
that proves the President Trump is a
Russian catspaw Eugene Robinson is a
commentator for the Washington Post
who's appearing on MSNBC he said most
democratic primary voters want
impeachment and herein lies in a
conundrum for a lot of Democrats the
base wants impeachment the rest of the
country does not want impeachment so
what do they do
here's Eugene Robinson laying it out
most Democrats primary voters want
impeachment so sure why I mean I expect
the chillier more from from the
candidate maybe loud enough that it
almost forced his policies hand I don't
think that's how policies hand would be
forced I think if she saw a huge
groundswell of popular support for
impeachments a giant demonstrations or
something like that I think that would
have more impact than 2020 contenders
saying impeachment you know Danny I do
think sometimes and that of course is
true and when Eugene Robinson says that
it would be you'd had to take people out
in the streets to push Nancy Pelosi in
this direction it's not gonna be enough
for politically motivated politicians to
just push it from the presidential level
he is correct about that but those
protests are probably in order because
this is where AOC is going Rio si has
declared the president Trump is
Hitlerian the only solution to Hitler is
to depose him and thus impeachment
should be on the table and Nancy Pelosi
is really trying to reproduce II
shouldn't like that fight that happened
a couple of weeks ago she wasn't fond of
being called racist by OSI now she had
the upper hand
a moment and then Trump proceeded to
give a OC the upper hand it is it is
simply a fact that Pelosi was winning
that fight most House Democrats had
turned on a OCS chief of staff psychotic
or Bharti who had ripped many members of
the Congress including some minority
members of the Congress as racists in
the Jim Crow fashion and Nancy Pelosi
had basically 6 her dogs on psychotic
labardi Chakrabarti was losing a OC was
about to be marginalized and then Trump
stepped in and Leroy Leroy Jenkins the
whole thing well now AOC is trying to
make peace with AOC at least for the
Pelosi trying to make peace with AOC at
least for the foreseeable future
AOC met with Pelosi yesterday and now
cou said yeah it's just we're making
sure we're all on the same page the goal
is just to open a line of communication
and making sure that that we're all on
the same page on everything I think the
objective is is just that to make sure
that we're opening a line of
communication that all aspects of the
party are on the same page and to make
sure that you know for me as always that
working people have a seat at the table
and what's happening in Congress yeah as
opposed to Nancy Pelosi who despises
working people now we live in is is we
have a visual representation of Nancy
Pelosi sees reaction to her meeting with
AOC so Pelosi tweeted out this picture
it's a picture of them standing next to
one another and she said today
congresswoman representative AOC and I
sat down to discuss working together to
meet the needs of our districts and our
country fairness in our economy and
diversity in our country Nancy Pelosi
looks like she wants to die AOC is
perfectly comfortable Nancy Pelosi who
always looks as though the grin that she
has his plastered on to her face it
looks as though it has been chiseled
there with an actual chisel and she
looks so deeply uncomfortable somebody
who is Dan Foster from National Review
tweeted out that Nancy Pelosi should
should blink twice if she's okay and it
does look like a hostage vote Pelosi is
deeply unhappy about this whole routine
where she is supposed to pretend to be
friends with AOC and the reason she's
deeply unhappy about that is because she
knows that a o'seas general strategy
when it comes to the public debate is
really dumb and as he proved that again
yesterday so AOC suggested that the GOP
is running a torture program on the
border so not only are they running a
concentration camp on the border now
it's a torture
program on the border pretty soon she's
gonna be out there declaring that
President Trump is running the island of
dr. Moreau on the border where he's
creating human animal hybrids you know
humans with pigs faces and hindquarters
of a horse
here's aoc with her latest slur on
border patrol how do you respond to
Republicans who are talking about
physical barriers being part of any
package that deals with the actual
crisis in terms of the traffic coming
across they wanna do that
that's have them negotiate and
appropriations have them make their case
but they should not be using a
humanitarian crisis as a bargaining chip
to make sure that they pursue their
little torture projects torture press
she's so obnoxious and she's so I mean
it's just such a lie a torture project
you think that Border Patrol agents are
interested in torturing people on the
border now Democrats are pointing to
this border patrol Facebook group and
they're pointing to the fact that
something like ten Border Patrol agents
posted comments in this Facebook group
that are gross and nasty and those
agents are under investigation and now
they're trying to tie all 10,000 agents
or members of this Border Patrol group
to those ten commenters so Huffington
Post today has a piece called Trump's
Border Patrol chief was in secret racist
Facebook group okay
you can't label the entire group racist
because there are ten commenters who say
racist things in the comment section
that is not how Facebook works it's
amazing how people who cover tech for a
living who write for web sites don't
seem to understand the very basic things
about how things like Facebook work
instead they just propagate this myth
that the entire Facebook group is
inherently racist and everybody who
joined the Facebook group is inherently
racist because some of the comments are
racist well by that token you can go to
any comment section on literally any web
site find the few people who are the
grossest and then slur the entire
website via the comments that is not how
any of this works but when you're trying
to paint a narrative then I guess that
you go forward with this sort of
nonsense and the squad of course is now
being magnified by the media the media
who do not have to legislate they do not
understand the difference between Nancy
Pelosi's job in their own job they think
that they could be Nancy Pelosi if only
they were given the leeway just like too
many people on the right thing they
could be given they could be Mitch
McConnell
any circumstances even if they've never
been elected to a public office there's
this weird idea that the commentariat
knows better than the people who are
actually legislating how to get things
done and so they're giving all sorts of
credence to the squad so the New York
Times grants a column to Ilhan Omar and
the same New York Times that said that
when she said anti-semitic things she
was just opening a conversation now
they've granted her some sort of op-ed
in the New York Times talking about how
the nation's ideals are under attack and
of course it is just a long screed about
how terrible President Trump is and how
she stands for the best of America how
she knows the true value of democracy
which apparently includes slandering
anyone who disagrees with her on Israel
as a as a purveyor of dual loyalty yeah
and of course she moves on suggest that
every policy that Republicans have is a
reflection of their underlying racism in
all of us okay so this battle is
breaking out into the open as I say
about impeachment Nancy Pelosi is
opposing the impeachment so according to
according to Politico today House
Judiciary Chairman Jerry Nadler pushed
to launch impeachment proceedings
against Trump during a closed-door
meeting on Wednesday only to be rebuffed
by Speaker Nancy Pelosi according to
four sources familiar with the
discussions at a caucus meeting that
came after the hotly anticipated
testimony of former special counsel
Muller Nadler suggested that several
House committee Chiefs begin drafting
articles of impeachment against Trump
Pelosi called that idea premature
according to the sources Muller's
appearance was a disappointment of
course Pelosi convened the Democratic
caucus and a lengthy and animated
discussion about the impeachment process
followed suffice it to say that the
battle between Pelosi and the squad is
not nearly over then it could be fought
along the lines of impeachment and that
is going to accelerate up into the
presidential race because now what
you're gonna see is the more woke
members the the more radical members of
the 2020 Democratic presidential race
declaring that they are in favor of
impeachment have already seen this from
Elizabeth Warren and Kamala Harris
you've seen Joe Biden be a little bit
more circumspect so this is now the
conflict inside the Democratic Party the
folks who are who are radical and the
folks who are more practical now the
entire agenda is radical make no mistake
and so if you're a Republican if you're
a conservative there's part of you that
is rooting for the more radical there's
part of you that is rooting for AOC to
win why because she'll be less effective
in the same way that many Republicans
are rooting for Bernie's
when the Democratic primary because they
think he's more beatable but as we found
out from the Democrats in 2016 be
careful what you wish for the fact is
that Nancy Pelosi is still at least in
some sense a rational human being with
which some Republicans can talk that is
not true of AOC and if you're rooting
for a better American discourse you want
less AOC and more Pelosi I can't believe
I'm saying this I can't believe these
words are exiting my mouth but that is
the reality if you are looking for a
better American politics you want people
who at least are capable even if they
won't do it are capable of having a
conversation as opposed to the squad the
AOC crew the impeach now crew who are
not capable of having a conversation
they're capable only of virtue signaling
and declaring that their political
opponents are evil for not favoring
their special political means okay in
just a second we're gonna get to the
2020 presidential race where it looks
like the guns are about to open up and
things are about to get really
interesting but first communication and
politics is key so is communication in
marriage but if we're honest some things
are kind of rough discussing with your
spouse or with anybody for that matter
one of those things of course is sex
even though 52% of dudes over the age of
40 and 26 percent under the age of 40
experience erectile dysfunction studies
show 70% of dudes who experience eg
don't actually get treated for it that's
what our friends at Roman come in
thankfully Roman has created an easy way
to get checked out by a doctor and get
treated for IDI online with Roman you
can get medical care for IDI if
appropriate from the comfort and privacy
of your own home you can handle
everything online in a convenient
discreet manner getting started really
simple just head on over to get Roman
comm slash been complete an online visit
if your doctor decides treatment would
be a good idea they can prescribe
genuine medication that can be delivered
in discreet packaging directly to your
door with free two-day shipping dude go
talk to the doctor right now
easy can be tough to tackle it's
important to get it checked out with
Roman it's easy to connect with a doctor
and keep everything just as subtle as it
should be just go to get Roman comm /
Ben get a free online visit free two-day
shipping that's get Roman calm / Ben for
that free visit to get started get Roman
calm / Ben go check them out right now
okay so all of this is leading up to the
big democratic debate all of this is
leading up to the big democratic debate
where impeachment I'm sure will come up
whether the split between the squad and
Nancy Pelosi well it should
and where that split is going to be
reflected on the stage now the set up
for the actual debates kind of
fascinating so these are happening next
it the first group appears at July 30th
so today is the 26th that means what
Tuesday night so Tuesday night is the
first debate and then the second debate
is Wednesday night the first debate
features Marianne Williamson Tim Ryan
Amy Klobuchar Pete Buddha judge Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren bethe O'Rourke
John Hickenlooper
John zeleny and Cibolo so it's the
all-white group is what the media have
termed it's the all-white group the only
person who is really of color there is
marianne williamson and that's just
because she reflects the colors of the
universe inside her soul everybody else
is is a plain old white person that one
will be fascinating only because of the
conflict between Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren the polls are
conflicting over whether Warren has
completely stolen Bernie's mojo or just
partly stolen
Bernie's mojo watching them go at it
will be amusing to say the least so we
can all look forward to Bernie versus
Warren it's a big opportunity for him
because if she really pummeled Sanders
if she demonstrates that she's sort of
souped up Sanders then she'll do some
pretty heavy lifting there but everybody
the real question is what happens on
night to night to is where all the
fisticuffs are set to happen so you've
got the gadflies you've got Kirsten
Gillibrand I'm sure who will be out
there desperately seeking attention just
as you did last time
Andrew yang who is still my favorite of
all these candidates who I'm sure will
say a grand total of four words and then
gain in the polls which is exactly what
happened last time he got Bill DeBlasio
the weird groundhog Keller giant
Frankensteinian groundhog killer got jay
Inslee who for no reason is still in
this race Tulsi Gabbard who is Matt
drudges favorite Democratic candidate
and the favorite candidate of some folks
on the right because she's sort of a
gadfly as well you've got Michael
Bennett who's the only you reach over
the only reasonable person in this race
Michael Bennett's the only person who
looks sane I mean he's the only one who
looks halfway sane in any of this and
then you have Julian Castro who was
supposed to pick up in the polls after
his debate performance last time that
really didn't happen but the key to that
debate is going to be Joe Biden Cory
Booker Kamala Harris Joe Biden Cory
Booker and Komal Harris that is the key
to that debate why because this is all
about Biden at this point right so these
debates next week are going to be about
Joe Biden pure and simple
does Biden collapse or does Biden
recover in the last debates you remember
that Joe Biden kind of fell apart under
attack from Kamala Harris the vice
president who is leading in all the
polls nationally and leading in many of
the state polls he sort of came apart at
the scenes he didn't have great
responses to khamel Harris he was taken
unawares apparently he thought everybody
was gonna treat him with kid gloves and
why wouldn't he think that just like
bata will work it's so funny folks get
lulled into a false sense of security in
politics because they think that the
past is prologue they think that
whatever just happened is likely to
happen to them in the future it's why
bata thought he was a legit presidential
candidate was like brah everyone treated
me great you know like way back when I
was running against Cruz I'm sure it'll
be the same now just like I'll just be a
bro all the way to the convention and
then he stepped in and boom he got
clocked on the head by an ACME piano
drop from the third storey and that's
because he wasn't running against Cruz
anymore well Joe Biden had the same sort
of impression Joe Biden thought okay
here's the deal
I was Barack Obama's VP Barack Obama is
the best politician of the last 30 years
since Ronald Reagan I was his VP he was
really popular
Barack loves me surely Barack will
endorse me ha ha ha
and then I will waltz my way to the
nomination everyone will leave me alone
because they'll be afraid to attack me
because attacking me means attacking
Barack and then he steps out in public
and Kamala Harris hits him with a
sledgehammer and he didn't see it coming
he looked he looked befuddled he looked
a little bit weak it was not a good
showing for Joe Biden now it hasn't
destroyed him because he did have this
giant lead on the field but it
definitely took him down about 10 points
anywhere from 5 to 10 points in the
polls and it gave a boost you Camela
Harris well now Joe Biden says he's not
going to sit by idly and let Carla
Harris do that to him again he says he's
not gonna be as polite to Carla Harris
this is correct he needs to go at her
when she attacks him on race which she's
surely well liked he shouldn't have said
this publicly right he really shouldn't
dub this is the other problem with
politicians they're constantly giving
away their strategy in advance and we
all know what Joe Biden has to do if we
were watching but Joe Biden apparently
feels the necessity to explain that he
will go after Camille Harris what he
really should do is just be subtle about
it he should just wait until commonly
Harris hits him and then he should knock
her into next week politically
she should say something about federal
busing and you should say listen qumola
now I agree that in certain
circumstances busing was wonderful is
wonderful for you but you don't support
busing right now why don't you support
busing right now and then she'll attempt
to redirect and says no no I need you to
answer my question that I'm happy to
answer yours why don't you support
busing right now when de facto American
schools are more segregated than they
were thirty years ago you're ripping on
me for saying that busing federal busing
was a bad idea
you're ripping on me for saying that
federal that opposing federal busing was
in some form racist because it was
imperative that blacks and whites go to
school together
well blacks and whites still aren't
going to school together but you don't
support a federal busing so why don't
you explain to the audience why exactly
you don't support federal busing I'm not
saying you're racist I'm just wondering
why it is that you think everybody else
is racist if they don't support a policy
prescription they you yourself will not
support I mean there's a lot of material
to go after Kamala Harris with a lot of
material and I'm sure that your Biden
has prepped for it hitting her out of
the blue would've been better but he's
gonna have to hit her anyway and as
we'll see Joe Biden is perfectly willing
to do that now you should have been
willing last time if you know it may not
be over for Joe by for ol Joe just yet
but he's gonna have to get pretty feisty
we'll get to that in just one second
first yeah one of them I'm good at some
things one thing I'm very very not good
at is sleeping I'm just not good at
sleeping I have a rough time sometimes
falling asleep I certainly if I wake up
in the middle of the night I have a
rough time going back to sleep that's
why I am so grateful for calm calm is a
great app it is the number one app for
sleep
his listen I like any other human being
I know I'm not a robot I may appear to
be but I'm not I need my sleep to sleep
deficiency can do serious damage not
just your brain buts your body as well
if you're sleep deprived you're not
thinking as clearly you don't have as
much energy during the day you can't get
done what you need to get done with calm
you'll discover a whole library of
programs designed to help you get to
sleep your brain and body needs
including soundscapes and over a hundred
sleep stories narrated by soothing
voices like Jerome Flynn from Game of
Thrones if you want to seize the day
first you need to sleep the night
so try calm right now I mean it'll knock
you right out the sleep stories are
really terrific also they have sleep
stories for kids so if your kids are
having problems falling asleep you
should get the app you know it'll put
your kids to sleep and I know parents
it's a relief right now my listeners get
twenty five percent off a calm a premium
subscription at
calm / Benton Etsy ALM dot-com / been 40
million people have downloaded calm find
out why at calm calm / pen that's calm
calm / then go check them out right now
promise it'll help you make your life
better
okay so joe biden he says it straight up
he's not going to be nearly as polite to
Kamala Harris as he was the first time
around have you and Senator Harris
talked since the last situation that he
had at the debate we I think I saw her
we in passing him I think it at the fish
fried for Jim Clyburn and said hi to her
we were no I don't know I'm serious look
wait I thought we were friends and we
wish I hope we still will be you know
she asked me to go out and call me and
asked me to go to her convention and be
the guy from outside of California to
nominate her at her convention for the
Senate seat I did we've talked we've
worked a lot together she and my son Bo
were attorneys general who took on the
banks but I think that I think the fish
fry was was AK was before the debate
okay so there is there is Biden saying
we used to be friendly now it's all
broken but he said at a Detroit
fundraiser quote I'm not gonna be as
polite this time he says this is the
same person who asked me to come to
California and nominate her in her
convention he said I did that so he is
not going to stand by nor should he nor
should he he said he was a bit surprised
by what happened in the debate that is
the marquee matchup of course he is
criticized Harris for her fantasy
proposals he said about her Medicaid for
all proposer of Medicare for all
proposal she claims she wouldn't raise
taxes on the middle class but somehow
she would achieve Medicare for all he
said come on I mean what is this is this
a fantasy world here also he's not going
to stand by while Cory Booker goes after
him so the way the stage is set up so we
actually know this according to the DNC
the way the stage will be set up Joe
Biden will be dead center and so it's so
obviously stage II we've got Joe Biden
dead center to one side will be Cory
Booker to the other side will become al
Harris right so they get the sandwich of
people trying to destroy Joe Biden
that's what this entire debate is going
to be about and Biden is saying I'm not
gonna stand by and listen to Cory Booker
malign me and it is true Cory Booker has
been going around mr. potato had gone
around with the angry eyes and he's been
putting on the angry eyes
every day about Joe Biden suggesting
that Biden is seriously a racist that
Joe Biden is easy on segregation
he's been suggesting all this here's
Biden starting to punch back it at Cory
Booker and folks who say that's punching
down now at this point because Booker
and Kamala Harris are tag-teaming him he
doesn't really have a choice they're
making the same critique and obviously
they're making the same critique for the
same political reason both Cory Booker
and Kamala Harris are black and they're
seeking to carve into Joe Biden's
massive lead among black voters in the
South so far with only moderate success
moderate to mild success moderate for
Harris none for Booker it is amazing
that Booker led off the attacks on Biden
and sort of like Chris Christie and 2016
just has not been able to get any
traction he's just too fake he's too
off-putting nobody likes him
here is Joe Biden saying I'll go after
Booker I'm not gonna be shy about this
one of the provisions I wrote in the
crime bill had in a practice of
misbehavior his Police Department was
stopping and frisking people mostly
african-american men we took action
against them the Justice Department took
action against them tell the police
department accountable
okay so canary is ripping into Cory
Booker and his handling of Newark again
this is all fair game things are
starting to get interesting and kind of
ugly now in a second I'm gonna explain
why one other Democratic candidate is
making headlines today in the lead-up to
the debates but first this month marks
the fiftieth anniversary since we put a
man on the moon exciting new podcast
that we've helped put out by esoteric
radio theater it's called the Powell 11
what we saw it immediately rocketed to
number three on the iTunes Apple podcast
and stayed in the top 10 for a week it
is getting rave reviews almost 1 million
people have listened to the podcast or
watched on YouTube but thus far the host
is Bill Whittle a dude who knows more
about NASA than any human being I've
ever heard of and he takes you on the
journey of what it took to get to the
moon and what happened when we got there
and how things almost went horribly
wrong all 4 episodes available right
this moment head on over to Apple
podcast or wherever you listen to
podcast subscribe today to Apollo 11
what we saw you can also watch this
beautifully produced video episodes we
made these they're amazing they include
tons of amazing space historical footage
at esoteric radio theaters
YouTube channel go check them out right
now also a reminder next month we're
taking our backstage show on the road
for one night
and one night only we're talking about
August 21st at the beautiful Terrace
Theatre in Long Beach California me
daily wear a god-king Jeremy boring
Andrew Clavin Michael Moe's we will all
be there live will be taking poets that
will be talking about politics and pop
culture will be answering your questions
from the audience
undoubtedly drew and I will get into
antic arguments about trade or something
tickets are on sale right now at Daley
wire.com slash backstage that includes
our limited VIP packages that guarantee
premium seating photos and
meet-and-greet with each of us a gift
from me I'm shopping for it right after
the show I keep promising this but just
like gifts for my wife I keep putting it
off but I promise you by the time the
date arrives there will be a gift head
on over to daily wear comm slash
backstage get your tickets today I'll
see you there go check it out also make
sure you subscribe obviously over at
daily wear calm it really helps us out
the left is incredibly vicious and
they've dedicated full-time staff to
just watching this show and trying to
take us out of context well if you want
to help us bring you the contents every
day please become a subscriber also when
you subscribe you got the leftist here
is hot or cold tumblr
look at this thing it's magnificent and
if you get one of those then you have a
shot of being featured here on the
program like Kyle at Kyle Missy AK who
has posted a picture of himself with a
leftist ears tumblr apparently near a
nuclear facility because nuclear
facilities are great and if you care
about the environment you should care
about nuclear also you can feel the
leftist tears overflowing his cup as he
moves toward a nuclear facility that
ironically helps lower carbon emissions
but for some reason the left hates
nuclear don't know why but that's the
way it is thanks Kyle and you too can
become a subscriber with hashtag leftist
here's tumblr go on over to daily wire
comm and subscribe right now we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
one other Democratic candidate is making
headlines today hubby Tulsi gabbard's Oh
Tulsi Gabbard delivered a fairly solid
debate performance she did not pick up a
lot of ground in the polling she
continues to pull pretty low in the Real
Clear Politics poll averages she's not
in the top ten of the candidates in that
average right now she is polling below
Julian Castro Amy clobbered shower cory
booker and andrew yang yang is pulling
2% in many of these polls and running
ahead of Booker which is just wonderful
the fact that Andrew yang is running
ahead of Cory Booker is the best
Andrew yang in many of these polls is
running ahead of bethe of work and again
the great shock to me when you look at
this polling data is that if there's one
candidate whose media attention has
wildly outpaced his actual performance
in the polls it's people who judge
Peabody judges averaging 5 percent he's
gotten coverage that is equivalent to
probably Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren
and Kamala Harris minimum maybe more
than many of those folks he is still
riding at 5% nonetheless Tulsi Gabbard
is interesting in a lot of weird ways
she is certainly a gadfly she's a person
with different views on a lot of the
issues the Democrats care about she sort
of appeals to the horseshoe theory of
politics her isolationism is appealing
to a lot of sort of paleo con
conservatives well now representative
Gabbard the longshot presidential
candidate from Hawaii according to the
New York Times said in a federal lawsuit
that Google infringed on her free speech
when it briefly suspended her campaigns
advertising account after the first
democratic debate in June the lawsuit
was filed on Thursday for 50 million
dollars against Google in the twist that
reflects her unorthodox political views
the claimant that her speech was stifled
by Google is similar to complaints made
over the last year in Republican circles
few Democrats have raised similar
concerns and it is true that there are
certain Google algorithms that benefit
Democrat ideas this has been true for a
very long time just a couple of years
ago there was a case where Google was
putting fact-check ratings on right-wing
sites only but not on left-wing sites
for example and these big tech companies
are getting a lot of scrutiny is it true
that they cracked down on Tulsi Gabbard
or was this just a mistake this is one
of the big questions that it's hard to
get your mind around simply because the
vast number of things that Facebook or
Google deal with it's so vast that an
isolated incident if it's taken for
pattern it may not actually be a pattern
nonetheless the fact that Gabbard is
going after Google is a quite
fascinating story we've reached out to
Google for comments I'm sure that other
media outlets have as well tulsi now inc
is the campaign committee for Gabbard
they said that Google suspended the
campaign's advertising account for six
hours June 27th and 28th obstructing
their ability to raise money and spread
her message to potential voters which
would have helped because she won The
Drudge poll and while that poll is not
nearly representative it is publicity
after the first democratic debate
Gabbard was briefly the most searched
for candidate on Google her campaign
wanted to capitalize on the attention
she was receiving by buying ads but
apparently Google either decided to turn
her off which i think is kind of
unlikely or they got fooled and when
they started suddenly pumping ad money
behind a particular cause Google always
sort of puts a hold on that to make sure
that it's legit so unclear whether
that's political bias or not but kind of
fascinating that that's direction that
Tulsi Gabbard is going okay meanwhile in
other news the house did pass a two-year
budget deal to lift the debt ceiling and
suspended to lift spending and suspend
the debt ceiling yesterday it is a very
very bad budget deal okay the House
passed this budget deal that is going to
spend an additional 320 billion dollars
in basically unfunded spending and
Republicans mostly did not back this the
vast majority of Republicans did not
back in 149 people voted against this in
the House it passed 284 to 149
supporters said that the legislation was
a signal product of divided government a
compromise with something for everyone
to love or hate in reality it's just
something for everybody to love spending
and ever it's something for everybody to
hate which is spending lawmakers and
both parties are happy about all of this
because after all no one ever gets
busted in American politics for standing
for more spending name the last
candidate in American politics who
really got clocked for spending too much
money you can say the tea party started
because of Barack Obama overspending
there is some truth to that it is also
true that Barack Obama was an outsize
politician whose coattails did not
extend as far as they were supposed to
and there was a huge backlash against
the audacity of his programs not really
against the spending itself as we find
out as soon as Republicans are in power
they are willing to spend up the wazoo
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
basically
that clear yesterday he came out he said
yeah we gotta pass this budget because
the budgets great we just got to do it
we got the number we wanted on defense
but there will be no Democratic riders
what we call poison pills to pursue
their left-wing agenda all of those are
walled off and it'll be a chaos free
government for a year and a half in
other words no short-term CRS no
short-term debt ceilings it will at
least present to the American people
what they would expect mm-hmm which is
that the government would operate in a
normal fashion I think that's worth a
lot that we knew we'd have to give with
this Democratic House more spending on
the domestic side we knew that going in
I think secretary Manu okay so there is
Mitch McConnell basically signing up to
endless spending without any cutbacks at
all and you can see how this plays out
in real time because there was this 911
responders bill everyone is in favor of
supporting funding for 911 responders
including Rand Paul and Mike Lee Rand
Paul Mike Lee said we need to find a way
to fund this and people went down their
throats people were enraged how dare
Mike Lee and Rand Paul ask very simple
questions about where the money is going
to come from on this thing how dare they
hold up a bill for like two days three
days in order to find out whether this
is just spending into infinity because
apparently it doesn't cut off money for
like a hundred years or whether we can
figure out a way to fund this thing no
one wins points in American politics by
talking about cutting spending when
they're in a position to actually cut
spending you only win points when you
are not in a position to cut spending
and that's how these sorts of budget
deals get done no one has the political
courage of their convictions it's why no
one talks about Social Security Medicare
and Medicaid which represents 66 percent
of the federal budget if we were to talk
about that particularly Social Security
we would have to talk if we want to fix
it we'd have to talk about a combination
of privatization for people who are not
on Social Security now cutting up future
benefits for people not under Social
Security right now raising the
retirement age for people not under
Social Security right now and or raising
the Social Security tax rate which is
already 12% all the way up to 15% and so
the the move toward fixing that thing is
not going to happen until crisis is upon
us at which point we'll say it's an
emergency old people are suffering now
sign the check that's always how
politics
and that's why you hear that that's why
we always push up to the very last day
on these budget deals because the crisis
is the solution for the politicians the
crisis represents the solution because
oh my god we can't have a debt ceiling
shutdown again we can't have a
government shutdown that would be the
worst okay we've had so many government
shutdowns in the last ten years have any
of them proved catastrophic truly catus
time we hear the media talk about the
end of the world everyone's going to die
zombies in the streets and then the
thing goes for like four or five weeks
and some people miss their paycheck and
then they get back pay when that when
the shutdown is over and then we all
move on with our lives
if it was so devastating for the
American economy why have we had
unalloyed growth for years on end at
this point it's just a way for
legislators to claim over and over and
over that they have no solution except
to continue spending your money in other
news it is worth noting that Iran
continues to grow more and more militant
yesterday on a radio program we had on
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo he
continues to push forward in his quest
in the Trump administration's quest for
hard-hitting sanctions and it's starting
to come together the plan is starting to
come together for the United States he
said there would be a multilateral naval
force likely to form in the aftermath of
the Iranians attempting to target
shipping in the Straits of Hormuz and
the Gulf of Oman according to the
Washington Post the British Navy has now
begun escorting vessels traveling
through the Strait of Hormuz after
Iranian forces seized a British flag
tanker now make no mistake the Europeans
are still not on board with the United
States sanctions they're still not
interested in the USS sanctions efforts
however they are not willing to violate
those sanctions because the United
States will punish companies that do
violate those sanctions we have
secondary sanctions that have been
placed on companies that do business
with Iran so now the British have been
forced to defend their own shipping
which is the proper solution in a
statement on Thursday Britain's Defense
Ministry said the Royal Navy has been
tasked to accompany British flag ships
through the Strait of Hormuz either
individually or in groups should
sufficient notice be given of their
passage that means that you could see
more naval conflict the HMS Montrose a
Royal Navy's type 23 frigate became the
first navy ship to offer an escort in
the narrow waterway according to Sky
News citing shipping industry sources
Britain made that decision after the
IRGC that's the Iran's Revolutionary
Guard Corps on July 19th sea
the Sena Impero a British flag tanker as
it passed through the Strait of Hormuz
Iran claims that the boat was using the
wrong channel through the Strait had
turned off at signals for longer than a
lab but the seizure was widely
interpreted as a response to British
Marines taking part in the seizure of an
Iranian flag tanker near Gibraltar a
British overseas territory and so it's
pretty obvious at this point that
European shipping is under attack it is
also obvious that the Iranians are
exploiting exactly the loopholes in the
Iran nuclear deal that everybody said
they were going to exploit so Iran
nuclear deal was specifically designed
in cowardly fashion by the Europeans and
the Obama administration to take into
account only the nuclear program the
idea is that we would stymie their
nuclear program for 10 or 15 years and
meanwhile we will grant them regional
power by funding them with billions of
dollars in cash and allowing them to
spend that money on terrorism and
ballistic missile testing the minute
that the sunset period was over wasn't a
permanent deal to denuclearize you could
make the argument that if it was a
permanent II nuclearization deal then
maybe it's worth while that if the deal
wasn't a 15-year sunset a deal that if
the United States and Europe it said
listen
you dismantle all your nuclear
facilities there will be no fissile
material created in your country you
don't need nuclear power you're one of
the world's leading producers of natural
natural gas and oil that if that had
been a forever deal then maybe it's a
deal that's worth considering but it
wasn't a forever deal it was like a 10
12 15 year deal which means Iran becomes
regionally powerful test ballistic
missiles that they will undoubtedly tip
with nuclear weapons at the first
available opportunity and then you put
them on the pathway to a nuclear weapon
by limiting their capacity to develop a
nuclear weapon only to a percentage so
it's not a complete denuclearization
it's not getting rid of all their
nuclear facilities
it is simply diminishing their nuclear
capability such that it would take them
a few months to spin the thing back up
after these after this this waiting
period is over well now Iran is doing
exactly what you would think they're
doing they're pushing up against the
boundaries of that deal they tested
another ballistic missile today Iran has
reportedly tested the shahab-3 missile
and traveled a thousand kilometers it
did not pose a threat to shipping or US
bases according to a Pentagon official
apparently they tested the medium-range
with missile on Wednesday in a bid to
improve improve the range and accuracy
of their weapons news of that
provocation emerged according to the UK
Sun
after Prime Minister Boris Johnson
ordered the Royal Navy to accompany all
British flag ships through the Strait of
Hormuz this is pretty it's pretty
obvious what is happening here what is
happening here is that the Iranian
government is feeling the sting of the
sanctions they're feeling insecure and
because they're feeling insecure they
are attempting to lash out at the
Europeans in an attempt to bring them
back to the table to re-enter the
nuclear deal well if the nuclear deal is
so good for Iran but they are lashing
out and getting militant in order to
enforce it it's probably not a great
idea is it it's probably not wonderful
so the Iran nuclear deal which is seen
by many on the left is the great
solution to this problem actually
exacerbated the problem because either
Iran was going to get militant in Yemen
Lebanon Iraq and Syria or Iran was gonna
get militant with us right now they're
getting militant with us because we have
sanctions on them if we didn't have
sanctions on them they'd be taking that
money and they'd be using it for
terrorist activities all across the
world including in South America in
Africa and other parts of the world
where they funded terrorist entities so
Iran continues to do what they're doing
the good news is that the world is being
forced into a position of taking
protective measures against its own
assets which is a really good thing okay
one more piece of news and then we'll
get to the mailbag so aoc tweeted
something out yesterday that is really I
think foolish what she tweeted out was a
was a take on an unpaid internship she
tweeted out today I was asked why we
should bother paying interns if they're
quote getting experience for their
resume here's what we have to say about
that then in a video of her and Rasheeda
Talib and Layana Presley all shouting at
the camera which is always a wonderful
way to do things
they were shoot to leave is laughing I
Anna Presley as befits the Ringo star of
this particular group joins in late on
the party experience doesn't pay the
bills okay so what is she talking about
here I'm all in favor of if corporations
want to pay their interns go for it but
if what you're saying is that we need to
legislate it so that corporations must
pay interns
you know corporations are gonna do not
hire interns you know how I know this
because we do it here okay we here are
in California in California the rules on
internship are extraordinarily strict
you're supposed to pay your interns well
if I as an employer have a choice
between paying someone who is highly
qualified and an intern I'm gonna pay
somebody who's highly qualified am I not
why would I pay somebody to learn the
job I need to pay someone to do the job
an internship is a way for people to
gain a foothold in an industry that they
may not know and for folks who are
saying well there are lots of people who
are too poor to take internships that's
true which is why there are a lot of
people who actually take a job on the
side and work an internship we've had
people who have done that here I mean
you do this when you go to college when
you go to college you take out student
loan debt to learn a skill sets now I'm
not saying that it wouldn't be better if
everybody had the money to pay interns
to learn a job I'd be wonderful that'd
be very nice but most small businesses
particularly are not going to do that
instead they're just gonna hire people
if they have to pay people and they're
not gonna give people opportunities to
sit around the office if it creates
legal liability it's easy for alc to say
that interns should be paid when she's
not paying anybody the taxpayers are
paying everybody and I see people on the
right who are saying sure interns should
be paid okay are you saying that as like
a governmental standard or as a I wish
interns were paid standard I wish
everybody was paid but the idea that the
government is gonna cram down internship
rules on businesses all that's gonna do
is end internships you ain't gonna see
any seventeen year olds walking around
the office getting paid minimum wage to
learn how to carry coffee and work the
work the Xerox machine that's not how
any of this works but the beautiful
thing about being a Democrat is that you
never actually have to operate in the
world of business reality this isn't an
anti-poverty point this is a pro
economics point this is a pro you get to
consent to the job you want to take
point and by the way to pro opportunity
points is there a lot of folks who have
gotten internships at prestigious
programs and who are not wealthy and
they've used that as a foothold to get
into industries that they've desperately
sought to answer okay time for some
mailbag so lets mailbag it up for a
little while here all right Troy says
hey Ben
after watching the Muller hearing I was
surprised to see that the top trending
hashtags on Twitter were impeach now an
impeachment inquiry now where we're not
watching the same hearing are people
just blinded by their hate for the
president thanks for all you do okay so
a couple of things about Twitter's
hashtags it is pretty obvious that
Twitter does censor its hashtags and
picks which hashtags that wishes to
elevate it is not automated there are
many hashtags that seem like they should
be trending that simply do not trend and
that is because in my humble opinion
backed by some anecdotal evidence it
seems that that Twitter will shadow
banned particular hashtags
second of all twitter does this by
velocity they don't do it by sheer
number of tweets so that means that if a
thousand people tweet something in quick
succession
it is likely trend on Twitter which is
why people have hash tag campaigns also
when it comes to Twitter hashtags the
fact is it doesn't take that many people
tweeting a hash tag before to trend
sometimes you'll see that with a
thousand or two thousand tweets
something will have will trend
I've trended what five times in the last
eight weeks my name on Twitter and in
many of those cases it's like fifteen
thousand tweets total I have 2.2 million
followers who cares so Twitter hashtags
are not a good representation of this
Twitter is also not representative of
American life and it has really
perverted how we do politics in this
country Kevin Williamson has a really
fantastic new book out about social
media mobbing and Twitter is basically
that and politicians who take Twitter
too seriously are going to lose the
middle of the country because the real
world is not Twitter I mean we all say
this on Twitter but we don't take it
seriously cuz we're in it it is true the
real world is not Twitter I know this
because every time I turn off Twitter it
goes away it's amazing
you can't do anything else like that in
your life there's nothing else in your
life that is like this if god forbid
somebody in your family has cancer you
can't turn it off and it just goes away
and if your kid has a problem at school
you can't turn it off and it just goes
away if you've got a problem on Twitter
you have a magic solution it's called
put your phone in your pocket it's
pretty great Edwards says the weeping of
pregnant representative Erika Thomas
stirred my male instinct to defend the
female sex of my species isn't this ant
the antithesis to the female feminist
Creed and what about the representatives
daughter what lessons did she learn it's
not okay to follow rules and I've caught
to play the victim loudly and without
civility is our culture on the precipice
of disaster well our culture is in
disaster we don't have a common culture
anymore our common culture is relegated
to once in a while we watch a season
finale together and the rest of the time
we yell at each other
and that's really ugly and that's
because a lot of the aspects of common
culture that we used to share
aspirational aspects of culture those
have gone away in the 1950s which were
great for some reasons and really bad
for some other reasons obviously in the
1950s more people went to symphony
orchestra events than went to baseball
games has an amazing statement that is
people trying to engage with their
culture today nobody tries to engage
with their culture the culture is
supposed to come to you and appeal to
you at lowest-common-denominator beyond
that everything that is cultural is now
political
and so you cannot watch a movie you
cannot go to a concert you cannot view a
sporting event without being clubbed
over the head with divisive nonsense
it's really negative as far as the male
instinct to defend females
yes it seems fully foolish for feminists
to claim that the best thing would be
for men to stop defending them you know
what happens in cultures where men don't
defend women they look a lot like some
of the most primitive cultures on earth
women standing up for themselves is a
thing you know it is necessary for women
to stand up for themselves men to stand
with them obviously the story of
feminism is not just the story of women
learning to stand up for themselves it's
the story of men standing with them
women were only able to vote in the
United States because men voted to give
women the right to vote women couldn't
vote so how could they vote to change
their votes so good men always have to
stand on the side of women feminists who
throw that away we think chivalry is bad
our idiots and and also feminists who
think that the sort of woke feminist man
who silences his opinion and recedes
into the background says ladies have the
first say women have the first say just
because they happen to have different
genitalia now those are not going to end
up being your allies you want you want
allies in justice and equality and
freedom you need men who stand up for
justice equality and freedom not men who
stand against those things when
feminists tell them to stand down
Stephen says you have any thoughts on
the North Korean missile test is a time
for military option well obviously look
the big problem with a military option
is that there's an inordinate amount of
ordnance right on the border between
North Korea and South Korea much of it
is pointed at Seoul there there have
been a lot of estimates as to what the
death toll would be if open war broke
out on the Korean Peninsula it could be
a hundred thousand in Seoul alone and
those are huge numbers and wrote
terrifying numbers a military option
obviously is the last option the Chinese
need to continue to be pressured and the
Chinese are not are not cutting off the
North Koreans in precisely the way that
they should be cutting off the North
Koreans I'm not sure there is any easy
solution to the North Korean problem
just as I'm not sure that there is any
great solution to the Cuban problem
dictatorship is very difficult to get
rid of particularly when that
dictatorship is fairly well contained in
a in a small area as dictatorships grow
larger then there's always the
possibility that they collapse
due to their own way that's what
happened in the USSR but when your Cuba
and you're a tiny island and you have
only a few million citizens it's not
that hard to keep control the same thing
is true in North Korea particularly if
you can threaten force to the outside
world honestly there's a better argument
for regime change in Cuba than there is
for regime change in North Korea in
terms of the actual risk it would entail
a Shura says in light of the release of
his ninth film are you a Quentin
Tarantino fan why or why not so I
certainly appreciate Quentin Tarantino's
ability to craft a scene my feeling
about Quentin Tarantino is that he is
effectively a filmmaker who makes
YouTube films that are a bunch of
YouTube films that are really good
pasted together for like two hours and
that those do not actually work as a
full-on movie and those don't actually
work as a complete movie I've never seen
one of his movies where I thought that
was great all the way through I think
his best movie is Reservoir Dogs still
because it actually is somewhat tight
but all the rest of them are very super
Alling he's somebody who needs an editor
there are some artists who need editors
ricard vogner needed an editor there
there certain authors who need editors
Quentin Tarantino needs an editor the
problem is the bigger he gets the less
anybody is willing to edit him and that
of course is a problem for him
let's see Alec says hey Ben my wife and
I are going to be adopting our second
son out of foster care next Monday we've
been foster parents going on four years
now we have seen and heard a lot of
heartbreaking stories in regards to
children in the system my belief is that
even though Child Services is a flawed
system the real problem lies in our
communities that are failing these
children my question is what can be done
on a local level to help fix this how
can we get more people involved in
helping these children in the meantime
well honestly most people are not up to
foster parenting foster parenting is
much more difficult than adoption for a
variety of reasons including the fact
that very often you get a fully-formed
kid right when you adopt you're getting
a kid very often he's a baby when you're
a foster parent sometimes the kid
arrives they're 6 7 years old they've
already had tremendously terrible
experiences and you have to deal with
that obviously we need more foster
parents but we really need to do is ease
in in adoption and instead we are making
it harder to adopt we're getting rid of
adoption agencies Catholic adoption
agencies on the basis of social justice
warrior crap the idea that if a Catholic
Church favors a traditional couple to
have to to receive a baby that this is a
form of bigotry and so shut down shut it
all down
that's what Massachusetts did that's not
good for kids we need to make it easier
to adopt
obviously that would certainly be one
possible
solution I know people right now
who are planning to adopt and they have
to go through this giant rigmarole
meanwhile the kid is being brought up in
a home by a mother who doesn't want the
kid and treats the kid poorly like how
is this a solution Jacob says Haman
I often hearing I often hear you
referred to Iran is the biggest sponsor
of terrorism around the world whenever I
read left-leaning sources they use the
same description with regard to Saudi
Arabia how's this measured or estimated
thanks for your work Jacob well
obviously Saudi Arabia does sponsor
terrorism and they have but the amount
of terrorism that is sponsored by Iran
by metrics that I have seen in world
metrics it pales in comparison to to buy
from Saudi Arabia to Iran Iran Iran
spends an enormous amount of money on
terrorist activities in Syria they fund
Hezbollah in Lebanon and if I'm Hamas in
in the Gaza Strip they have funded
terrorist activities in Europe they fund
terrorist activities in South America
now Saudi Arabia is still a serious
problem and the Wahabi mosque system
funded by the Saudis is a lot more
militant than other mosque systems that
are not funded by the Saudi royal
government and Wahhabism does carry some
dangerous seeds in my opinion not all
forms of Islam are equally dangerous
obviously there's some forms of Islam
that are perfectly fine and there other
forms of Islam that are much more
radical the Wahhabist version of Islam
is a much more radical version of Islam
when it comes to the actual sponsoring
of violent terrorism around the world
however it seems that the groups that
are sponsored by the Iranian seem to be
much more deadly than the groups that
are sponsored in general by the Saudi
government although I'd like to see
these statistical are kamini their way
honestly I'm willing to hear it
nidian says hi Ben do you think that the
Dems are gearing to do something big
gearing up to do something big like put
Michelle Obama in the running at the
last minute to surprise Republicans the
Obamas have been awfully quiet your
thoughts now I think that it's probably
not going to happen you know the idea
what we heard this in 2016 also was that
Michelle Obama was going to jet into the
middle of the primaries we heard in 2000
in 2020 they're still people speculating
that Hilary is gonna parachute into the
middle of the primaries it's really been
a long time since somebody parachuted
into the middle of a hotly contested
primary the last I can remember is Fred
Thompson tried to do this I believe in
2008 he tried to parachute into the
middle of the of the primaries and it
just collapsed in on itself Wesley Clark
I think did so in 2004 in the Democratic
primary's it just failed you have to
build an infrastructure you have to get
people excited ready to go look Michelle
Obama is a massive figure in American
politics I do not believe her when she
says she will not run for office frankly
I think that she is a very political
person she's always been a very
political person now she's more of a
cultural figure than a political one so
that means that she'd be a particularly
dangerous political figure in terms of
her innate capacity to win so I think
that she's up for 2020 I don't get that
impression from her at all you'll have
it says do you think the Republican
Party has any women who could be strong
presidential candidates in 2024 do I
think that I mean my spirit animal nikki
Haley at the UN obviously is one who
comes to mind you know condi is still
out there I don't think she wants to run
for president but she'd be a strong
presidential candidate obviously I'm for
anything that there are some others who
I know I'm missing here but the one who
comes to mind most obviously is Haley
and John says mr. Shapiro I love the
show but you are following short in one
area I want more Chris Matthews much
like Cabo there can be never be enough
good news for you next week about your
Democratic debates and no question Chris
Matthews gonna have him commentary those
Democrats here though he structure the
show yeah I roll on in here Harold
rumpled I'm kind of a mess and a roll on
in yet
maybe drunk maybe not you never know
let's have the surprise and then I just
gotta come in here and I don't see Chris
Matthew said anything yesterday PJ I
grab a clip of it and then I riff on it
for a little while we talked about
wandering around the hotel asking for
Kathleen we talked about why why the
wipey bootie judge really isn't gaining
momentum the kind of momentum you'd
expect from men in Peabody judge but if
there are no clips of Chris Matthews
they can't do anything about it he's not
been controversial of late so Chris do
your job and I'll do mine okay Logan
says hey Ben's you enjoy the Sherlock
Holmes stories the answer is yes it is
there right
okay I think maybe one or two more
questions Lewis says hi Ben I have been
a premium subscriber since January I've
never missed your show once Wow you know
practicing to become presidents of the
United States if they observe Shabbat I
would assume into President must be
available 24/7 thank you for everything
keep up the great work so the answer is
yes an Orthodox Jew could become
presidents of the United States because
obviously there is a provision of Jewish
law called peacock nefesh if life is
endangered and the president is allowed
to respond it is also true that the
president doesn't necessarily
have to violate Shabbat in order to get
things done
meaning that let's say that the
president they they ask the president
for a decision on something present
doesn't have to tweet about it
necessarily the president doesn't have
pick up the phone he's got a pretty big
staff so and and of course in cases
where there's a national emergency
situation where Iran shoots down a drone
or something you have to make a call
right now are people gonna die or are
they not gonna die then Orthodox Judaism
itself says okay you get to make an
exception now now you get to I mean my
wife who's a doctor right she was able
to do medicine on Shabbat because
p/kaufmann fish was at stake because a
life was at stake that is the one rule
that you can buy you can break Shabbat
any time a life is at stake
in presidential politics sometimes
that's going to happen honestly wouldn't
it be kind of great for the country if
everything's sort of shut down between
Friday night and Saturday night wouldn't
be kind of calming I got to admit I
think that it would be kind of great for
a listen my life is great because
between Friday night and Saturday night
I don't know what the hell's going on
it's fantastic and can you imagine like
just how much more popular Trump would
be if he didn't tweet on Saturdays just
like one day a week you should take a
tweet Shabbos a tweet Shabbat for
president Trump that's all I missing eat
I says hey Ben what's it day like
preparing for an episode of the ben
shapiro show it must be a lot of moving
parts to get any one episode done so I'm
fascinated by but behind the scenes
operation so I can tell you from my end
so first we take all of our producers
and we lock them in a room and then we
take then we take a dolphin and we throw
it into the middle of the room and
whoever the dolphin slaps first is
forced to cut the clips whoever the
dolphin slaps second is forced is forced
to quit and and this is the way that
that we've it out I mean we have a high
churn level but the show's quality is
really high in reality our producers are
treated only only in sort of moderate
horrible fashion mostly they're treated
horribly but sometimes not here's how it
works for me throughout the day I'm
watching the news as you can tell from
my Twitter feed and I sort of form ideas
what the narrative of the day is and
then when it comes time to put together
a schedule the night before I do the
show I put together a baseline schedule
because usually you kind of know what
the news cycle is gonna be the next day
and then in the morning I wake up and I
bombard my producers with a bunch of
clips I want them to pull I structure
everything so they they do a wonderful
job pulling the clips making sure
everything is ready to go making sure
all the technicals already I don't have
to do any of that that's why we have a
great staff here what I do
do is make sure that I am fully in like
I do all my own prep nobody does prep
for me one iota on the show other than
sort of pulling the clips that I suggest
that they pull so I can fairly say that
the show is a product of whatever is
going on upstairs which may or may not
be good okay quick thing you know what
we're gonna skip things I like in things
I hate today because the show has run
extraordinarily long and guess what it's
the weekend man I want to go home so
we'll see you here for two more hours
later today because it's not quite the
weekend for me yet if you want that go
subscribe to daily wire if not we'll see
you here next Monday prepping for those
Democratic debates I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today federal executions have been
reinstated and this fact has caused
quite a lot of anger and consternation
especially on the left one thing we keep
hearing which we hear about which we
hear a lot this claim that well if
you're pro-life you can't be Pro death
penalty is that actually true I say no
I'll explain why also a drag queen story
hour goes in an even creepier direction
than usual and that is of course saying
quite a lot so we'll discuss that today
also over on the Matt Walsh show